Hey Thoughty2 here.
The word Halloween is derived from "All Hallows'
Eve".
All Hallows' Eve is the eve before the Christian
feast of All Hallows on November 1st.
Halloween takes place on the 31st October,
mostly in the western world.
More chocolate and sweets are sold on October
28th than any other day of the year.
The most popular of which is Snickers.
Halloween is the second highest grossing commercial
holiday after Christmas.
Americans spend $6 billion on Halloween every
year.
But why do we celebrate Halloween?
Halloween started about 2000 years ago in
Ireland.
The holiday originated from the Celtic festival
of Samhain.
Samhain was celebrated by Celts in Ireland,
the UK and northern France.
The festival was held to mark the end of the
summer months and harvest time.
The darker, colder months that followed were
associated with death by the Celts.
Samhain began at sunset on October 31st.
They believed this was the time when the ghosts
of the deceased returned to earth, because
the boundaries between the world of the living
and the dead were most blurred.
So why do we call it Halloween today?
The word Halloween comes from the Christians.
Hallowmas is a three day Catholic holiday
where saints are honoured and people pray
for the recently deceased.
At the start of the 11th century, the Pope
decided that it would last from October 31st
until November 2nd because that's when Samhain
was celebrated and the church was trying to
convert the pagans.
October 31st, the start of this Christian
holiday is known as All Hallows' Eve, which
over the centuries has been shortened, first
to All Hallow's Even and eventually in the
18th century to Hallowe'en.
The Irish brought their Halloween-like traditions
to the US in 1840.
However the commercialised Halloween that
we know today didn't start in the western
world until 1921.
And mass production of Halloween costumes
didn't start until the 1950s, until then Halloween
costumes were homemade and just plain creepy.
But why do we dress up for Halloween in the
first place?
During the old festival of Samhain spirits
were believed to cross over to the world of
the living for this one night.
People began to get scared at the thought
of this so they wore handmade masks and odd
clothing in an attempt to disguise themselves
from the spirits so any evil spirits wouldn't
harm them.
Trick or treating is a tradition carried out
across most of Europe, North America and some
parts of Asia.
But the ritual of dressing up and knocking
on strangers doors in exchange for sweets
differs greatly in some parts of the world.
In France Halloween is seen as an unwanted
American influence and the French rarely trick
or treat.
In fact the French didn't fully celebrate
the holiday until 1996, because of the French
Catholic Church's strong campaign against
Halloween.
Instead of going house to house asking for
sweets, French children go from store to store.
In Germany it is customary to put away all
their knives, because they don't want the
returning spirits to harm themselves.
In Sweden Halloween is known as "Alla Helgons
Dag" and is celebrated for 6 continuous days,
school children are also given a day off.
In Spanish speaking countries such as Mexico,
Spain and Latin America, Halloween is known
as "El Dia de los Muertos", The Days of the
Dead.
Families remember their dead relatives by
constructing an altar in their homes, consisting
of flowers, candy, photographs, water and
samples of the deceased favourite food and
drinks.
But how did the tradition of trick or treating
originate?
It all started in England, across the West
Midlands and Lancashire, in the early 19th
century, when children would go "souling".
Kids would go door-to-door, singing songs
and begging for money, food and drink.
They would sing songs such as:
A soul! a soul! a soul-cake!
Please good Missis, a soul-cake!
An apple, a pear, a plum, or a cherry,
Any good thing to make us all merry.
One for Peter, two for Paul
Three for Him who made us all.
The most common treat given out were Soul
Cakes, they were small round cakes with a
cross on top.
Later in 19th century Britain, souling gave
rise to guising.
Where children would dress up and beg for
fruit and money, but instead of singing songs
to earn these gifts, children would put on
full blown performances such as playing instruments
and reciting poems.
This tradition eventually gave way to modern
day Trick or Treating when the Scottish and
Irish brought it to North America in 1911.
But is trick or treating really safe?
What about all those poisoned candy scares
and worried mummies?
Well you can relax, truth is you're more likely
to be ravaged by zombies that receive tampered
treats.
There have only ever been two documented cases
of people dying as a result of eating Halloween
goodies.
The first was in 1970 when a boy ate a large
amount of heroin that his uncle had hidden.
The boy's family sprinkled heroin on his halloween
sweets and blamed the sweets instead.
The second was when a father poisoned his
own son's sweets to get the compensation from
a life insurance policy he had just taken
out on him.
So what's the lesson here?
You should probably be more scared of your
parents than strangers.
And finally, why do we carve pumpkins?
In 19th century Great Britain, jack-o-lanterns
where a form of pranksterism, young boys used
to hollow out and carve faces in turnips to
frighten people on the streets.
Wait, what, turnips?
That's right before pumpkins, jack-o-lanterns
were created from turnips.
And the word "jack-o-lantern", well it comes
from 17th century Britain, when it literally
meant "man with a lantern".